[Musique]
pourquoi faire
ça me rappelle un peu ce qu'on avait
fait sur Marly de Monroe il y a très
longtemps on a les cousues sur elle mais
là c'est à rien et c'est une entreprise
qui a le brevet pour cette fibre liquide
qui vient dans des canettes et c'est
assez bon pour l'environnement en plus
parce qu'il y a pas de doses qui qui en
ressort ça et on peut avoir des trucs
vraiment sur mesure et une créativité
incroyable donc c'est
son corps
endommagés aussi grâce à ça justement ça
permet justement de faire moins de
gâchis et vous vous rendez compte du
coût de projecteur pour la France parce
que c'est quand même deux couturiers qui
viennent du sud de la France et c'est
juste génial parce que le coup de
projecteur est énorme là on voit leur
Instagram qui est en train de d'exploser
mais ça peut se reporter après
c'est une performance artistique c'est à
dire qu'elle a musique le podium il y a
la démarche tout est vraiment réfléchi
c'est pas pareil
alors là elle est méchant alors c'est
vous qui dit ça c'est les gens alors
essayez vous allez voir formidable
pourquoi ou juste là je la morphologie
on a l'impression 3D aussi
bon d'accord allez machine en 3D tu sais
que vous avez vu Kanye West aussi il est
venu
alors il est venu avec un G60 c'est un
avion privé vous en parler tout à
l'heure 450 000 dollars aller-retour
quand même oui je vous dis pas et alors
il a défilé ils ont pas eu beaucoup de
lumière apparemment c'était un peu
chelou
ça va être très très privé c'était très
c'était très très angoissant dans la
boue c'est pas assez glauque
[Musique]
c'est pas combien ils ont ils ont payé
Kanye West en fait il y a un concept
là-dessus parce que il voulait
représenter le bombardement qui a pu y
avoir en Ukraine et donc c'était un clin
d'oeil un peu immatériel par rapport à
ça
moi j'adore pas mais le styliste était
de Géorgie il a quitté en exil la
Géorgie pour l'Ukraine
de lui rendre hommage et ça fait pas de
lui un bain un bon styliste
des défilés c'est pas de mettre de
montrer des vêtements qu'on peut porter
c'est de montrer une identité de marque
de faire passer des messages en
l'occurrence un message politique mais
c'est pas le but c'est pas de porter ça
dans la rue c'est pas c'est pas ça la
politique tout de suite en regardant non
faut lire à travers les lignes